réaction de jean-luc aussi c'est ce faux
collier oui cette sombre histoire de
faux collier on va voir cette histoire
n'était pas une première et vous n'étiez
pas blanc bleu sur sept soit non non
c'est vraiment con et que j'ai beaucoup
aimé j'ai trouvé que c'était très fort
de fatwas faire coller à court terme
cette affaire qui a fait couler
énormément énormément d'encre sur koh
lanta non mais je vous ai dit mais moi
j'ai adoré
bravo c'est toi qui a eu l'idée du
collier non je vois une bijouterie
offert un bijou et on est certain que ça
irait magnifiquement bien beaucoup de
nathalie
[Musique]
je sais que sa mère chez qui sont à la
base c'était parce qu'à yacine et
envoyez moi je n'ai plus rien à [ __ ]
d'aucun membre de l'équipe des rouges
rien soyez elle était pâle qu'ils ont
fait un faux collier podium a compris et
elle a cru qu'elle avait trouvé un
collier d'immunité
oui est ce qui est vraiment drôle c'est
que nathalie elle a quand même tatouer
le totem de koh lanta sur la jambe
ben koh-lanta ça existe depuis 15 ans
avec elle croit que un morceau de
ficelle et trois coquillages c'est un
collier d'immunité
alors faut arrêter quoi je m'attendais
je viens nommé oui mais en tout cas on
peut se demander parce qu'ils disent
peut-être ils ont ils ont plus de zèle
parce que le collier de perles direction
faisait il avait on dirait le solliec la
côte est la fête des pères tu sais sans
rigoler collier de nouilles alors le
collier de nouilles oui oui yacine vous
qui êtes si pure ça c'est le moment vous
m'avez déçu comment vous avez pu
cautionner cette opération de faux
collier merci alors oui selon thomas
simart saison non mais c'est à dire que
vous avez des supercheries qui sont
tellement grosses mais tellement drôles
ou même énorme pour moi c'était
tellement évident qu'elle allait se
rendre compte de cette supercherie que
j'attendais le moment aussi que ça
allait se retourner contre javier donc
ces dons c'est dans ce but là que ça me
faisait rire par amiens et non non non
non là je peux pas dire ça parce que
c'est quelqu'un sur un lien
semblait radieux comme en 40 alors est
ce que je veux dire c'est que donc cette
histoire là je pense que cette blague
aurait pu être rigolade hier mais mais
c'est vrai que plus la blague avant
passé avant c'est exactement élevé plus
le temps défiler et moi elle devenait
marrant alors c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça que je je disais que au final la
chute est pourri quoi parce que parce
que voilà et même lorsque pascal prend
la parole au constat la chute du collier
d'immunité les ripoux ouais non mais
quoi l'imam est totalement et donc
pourquoi je n'ai rien dit à ce moment là
c'est parce que après ça devenait de
l'acharnement et s'était alors c'est
elle à la blague était pourri n'a pas
fonctionné j'allais pas son autre chose
une question à vous poser pour vous
quels candidats encore en lice ne
méritent pas d'y être
pourquoi alors donc c'est javier pour
vous vous pouvez pas le virer c'est une
séquelle je peux je peux pas s'il a deux
balles perdues la turquie balas et qui
moi c'est dommage que ça en est venu à
ce point là mais je dois être honnête
c'est pascal pascal maman qui élimine
mon binôme mais plus tu aimais à
batterie ça y est c'est comme les mises
en vente ont de larges pour le manteau
lourd
non mais c'est comme ça j'ai bien aimé
j'ai fait une belle aventure avec lui
mais avait dû remonter des copains en
binôme ouais ouais donc c'est donc tout
un choix qui me touchent moins c'est
comme ça tu vois ça tu touches à une de
ces femmes si on touche à un chroniqueur
cinéma tour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pareil et est donc et toi
honnêtement je pars du principe où tous
ceux qui crachent dessus nathalie
pasquet me crache dessus c'est dessus
sur moi ma vie je lui ai rien fait de la
fin de l'année si on voit là on a on a
tourné la page je j'ai donné mon
explication pour le pour le fauconnier
j'ai été on va dire plutôt correct et
malgré tout elle en voit encore des
messages comme sienne avec ça comme ça
mais mais on a il faut pas oublier qu'on
a quand même 40 piges quoi c'est vous
merina toulonnais 102 minutes malade
tout le shérif nathalie si tu viens ici
sur la tête de ma mère je t'offre un
collier mais de ouf collier une rivière
de boulettes
un jour je te plaît fermez actifs